Kelly is in Arizona
hi Kelly welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi thank you so much okay so I'm kind of
nervous and I tend to ramble so if I you
know start rambling just tell me to stop
and get back on okay wish my cure me to
you telling me - hey I'm in good company
good um so here's the thing is my
husband and I when we got married I
found out about that that he had I
didn't know about and so whether this
was the right choice or not my dad paid
it off so we would start out debt-free
and then I moved on to Arizona so this
is quite normal
didn't not a good an American Express
card for work because they didn't have a
work hardening how to pay for all of his
trips upfront and then get reimbursed
and I hated the idea of it but it was
well you've got to get it only for work
period nothing else just for work so he
should never have a balance and then
they came to Arizona and he needed a new
car and I got that so he bought a really
expensive car which I did not agree with
and I'm lied to me about how much it was
that she said it was about 38,000 in the
50,000 and then recently he wasn't sure
he was gonna get his bonus he did get
his bonus for work and that's when I
found out that the American Express has
been being used and he said it was about
ten thousand dollars there's actually
eighteen thousand dollars so we had to
use his bonus toward that although he
said it's still not fully paid off so I
hate that I'm allergic to it my dad has
taught me well however when I talked to
him about it he refuses to stop using it
he's made it clear she will still be
using a cart well I don't know what to
do with that because I mean I have no
control over it yeah I'm going to be
well mentally let's face it it's gonna
be hard I don't trust them every time I
speak and learn something new and I feel
angry because I'm like oh we just paid
off the money that you needed to put
furniture in our house with to pay off
your friend and you're wearing it in
front of me you know
here's the thing you guys regardless of
the credit card there's more going on
here you're simply not on the same page
with money okay well it's not the
conversation would sound like this the
marriage is the number one cause of
disagreement honey in America in
marriage and the number one cause of
divorce is money fights and money
problems and we have that we have the we
have we have been infected inside of our
home with the number one thing that ends
marriages this is going to end our
marriage if we don't work on it together
because it does everyone else's the
second thing is is that the that a study
of millionaires that we did we found
zero millionaires out of ten thousand
that we studied who became millionaires
against their spouses will they all
learned to work together so there's two
data points here that are very important
for him and you to come to agreement on
number one the number one cause of
divorce is money problems and
disagreements over money we have that
number two we're not unified and how
we're handling money and 100 percent of
the millionaires handle money together
in unity with their spouse we don't have
that so not only are we not destined to
have a great marriage we're also not
destined to build wealth
this is a problem and I think you need
to sit down with him and cut the TV off
and look into his eyes and explain to
him this is a problem having to do with
the credit card we're not on the same
page and we're not handling money
together and the way to start it is with
a good budget where the two of you agree
on all of your spending for your entire
household on paper on purpose and you
negotiate through the disagreements but
then we come to agreement and it's on
paper and it becomes a contract before
the month begins
and then you both stick to the contract
unless you sit down and both of you in
the middle of the month decide to adjust
it with an emergency budget committee
meeting for an adjustment because
something has come up
but what happens here is is that you you
don't have a contract and yet you're
trying to hold him to a contract yeah we
yeah we do have a budget the thing is
that because he thinks the American
Express is right it's just plain money I
don't get to know anything about well
the money that pays off the American
Express either comes from his company or
it comes out of your budget so you don't
have a budget you have a fantasy of a
budget you have a budget not counting
whatever he wants to take out of it to
pay the American Express and you're not
willing to put anything on the American
Express line item in the budget and he
is he has whatever he wants on that line
item because he makes it up every month
thus we have disagreement okay I see
what you say yeah so what would be
something you would do that he as a
behavior of yours
that he that would just infuriate him if
you just got up and left one afternoon
and went home to your mother's for the
weekend and didn't even tell him or you
went out with the girls and stayed out
till two o'clock in the morning you know
mine is more my attitude here yeah but
my point is is that he needs to hear
that when you do this it makes me feel
like it may it makes me feel the way you
would feel if I did that I'm not saying
you go engage in one of those behaviors
I'm just saying somehow you got to get
through this bozo because he thinks this
is no big deal and it's driving you
berserk yeah
so if I sit down and I have to then I
sit down and have this conversation with
them again but a little bit differently
and I talked about a budget for that
maximum sauce
there's no checks and balances there
shouldn't be in a budget for the
American Express because 100% the
American Express should be paid by the
company other than that he should buy
stuff out of your all's budget that he
made it clear he won't because he
doesn't want me he doesn't want me he
wants to spend whatever he wants to
spend which is a deal breaker for you he
needs to hear this
he's a liar Dave yeah Mary - you liar
yeah exactly
and there's arrogance here that's
unbelievable yeah you guys need to go
see a marriage counselor you sit down
with your pastor this is going against
this gonna run in the wall fast